[Music]
I'm Charlie Watson I'm 18 today actually
is the beetle for sale
yours kid happy birthday
[Music]
what are you
so you have no idea what he came from no
idea
[Applause]
well here's the deal people can be
terrible about things they don't
understand from now on the only person
you can show yourself around is me I'm
good now I'm good thanks
there's a war raging on our planet
if this criminal isn't found that war
may find its way sir anyone that can
help you you're the family
they're calling an army
I've seen firsthand these things really
are
bumblebee there is only one way to end
this war you must protect earth and its
people
this is how we stopped him
you've cut me
I'm not going anywhere
get out and move away from the vehicle
stay cool be what's going on birds now
take it down no don't run do that run
she ran
my heart right now is putting crazy
oh-oh
the car please what are you doing
[Music]
[Music]
it's a people can be terrible about
things they don't understand if they
find you they'll probably lock you up in
a lab somewhere it'll be bad trust me
the only person you can show yourself
around is me okay so let's practice you
ready you see anyone besides me what do
you do great perfect come back now okay
so let's say we're driving right we're
driving and all of a sudden Oh
[Music]
[Music]
people of Earth we are Decepticon
peacekeepers patrolling the galaxy we
believe a dangerous criminal from our
world is hiding somewhere on yours
there's a war raging on our planet
if be 127 isn't found bad war may find
its way here I play agent burns he is
head of sector 7 I've seen firsthand
these things really off in Sector 7 is
responsible for all of the things the
masses don't know about agent burns go
out and move offensively to hunt down
Rumble line it up and brings a whole lot
of equipment to do it there's a door in
my way John brings a physical presence
that's undeniable and that was part of
what the character needed to convey this
guy is a pillar of strength and once he
finds his prey he will pursue it
doggedly
[Applause]
she ran I really like the story begin to
care for these characters and inside
that you have this wonderful action take
it down
I loved everything about it
what I thought about the decepticons I
wanted them to evoke that feeling of the
eighties better and dropkick were the
first to triple changers we've ever done
in a live-action film the idea to have
triple changers in this film came from
the original toy line that you could
have something that transforms into a
robot and one vehicle and then a
separate vehicle and I think it's so fun
to see it in cinematic form we believe
that dangerous criminal from all is
hiding on yours these two Decepticons
they're the baddest of the badasses I
loved everything about it I play Charlie
Watson Charlie has this incredible
connection with what happens to be a
robot and a car this car is now her new
ticket to freedom
[Music]
one of the things that we try to
establish is how much these two are
mirrors of each other there's a family
oh-hoh bee bumblebee helps her discover
things about herself and he becomes more
like a best friend now I'm good thanks
movie you must protect people be would
do anything to save Charlie's IQ you can
see with just a look between the two of
them how much he cares and how much she
cares only you can save us be
I'm excited I can't wait for everyone to
see this I'm a child of the 80s I grew
up playing with the Transformers action
figures I grew up watching the animated
series when transformers hit I was right
in the middle
I vividly remember it transforming
Optimus Prime
it's awesome to go back and see where
Gumbel they came from we had all decided
we were going back to the 80s so we went
back to the gen one characters well
going back to my experience as a kid
Autobots were always cars Decepticons
were always aircraft we're simplifying
and squaring things out like the toy and
it conjures up that g1 aesthetic every
detail we could get off the cartoon we
applied to the characters it's great
that it's headed back to the beginning
set in the time period where I first
fell in love with transformer
[Music]
one of the things I love most about
filmmaking and storytelling is sharing
our experiences sharing our stories with
other people it's a way of connecting
with people Travis started a business
that was very successful
like as a cutting-edge stop-motion
animation company obviously we try this
background in animation he has an
incredible sense of being able to see a
drawing on the page brought to life a
Leica we try to find an artful balance
of darkness and light and intensity and
warmth and humor at heart the idea be
able to bring that kind of philosophy
Sodoma be was really exciting
I was a child of the 80s I grew up
loving those classics Spielberg and
coming-of-age tales and that was
something that I wanted to bring to the
humble be we get to go back in time with
bumblebee and see where he came from and
see him in his original form
Travis is taking a story back to the
beginning set in a time period where I
first fell in love with transformers
we'll take this big expansive franchise
and to focus in on a corner of that
canvas we really get to understand who
but will be is and why he will love it
this is why you're here be what we'll be
as an origin story holder bumblebee has
always been one of the beloved figures
this movie will allow the audience to
get to know if he away they've never had
before
you have no idea where he came from no
idea I think it's so incredible that we
go back in time and see where he came
from and see him in his original form
now I'm good thanks
one of the things we explore the film is
how bumblebee finds his voice probably
is the transformer that has the deepest
connection with humans and we're able to
explore how that happened is that why
you're always messing with the dial
you're trying to teach yourself at a
talk aren't you be you're a genius
Travis is taking the story back to at
the beginning set in a time period where
I first fell in love with transform
fumbly as an incredible journey and I'm
very excited to be part of it Oh movie I
want to call you that
[Music]
let me tell you something
a driver on picnic on
car picked the drive so mrs. kebab
between man and machines of mystical
bomb
between man
[Music]
[Music]
who are you do you speak owner
[Music]
[Applause]
you got people out they will need you
this is why you're here be
and Opie music can help you say what
you're feeling try this
[Applause]
[Music]